welcome back to me rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Avengers the endgame ended
with a tearful send-off to Captain
America that quote once the tears were
wiped and everyone started thinking
confused the hell out of everyone
including the film's directors and the
screenwriters who apparently disagree on
what the hell happened in the final
minutes and recently we just got some
clarification from the movies VFX team
who have been revealing the interesting
process behind how these crazy visuals
were put together including the
hilarious image of Mark Ruffalo checking
his teeth for breakfast scraps but also
a tidbit about Steve Rogers at the end
of the film and gain visual effects
producer John underdahl described are
they used a stand-in actor for cap and
then digitally swapped in Chris Evans
made-up face and worked his neck and
shoulders and nose to make him look even
more Clint Eastwood II and then she said
this so in the case of Captain America
what would a super soldier look like if
he had aged 106 years 106 years that's a
specific number in it's important
because it clarifies some of the
disputing details we've heard about Kats
timeline in the new history or histories
created by in game's final scene so
until now the directors Joe and Anthony
Russo have said that their
interpretation is that cap going back in
time to be with Peggy Carter creates a
new alternate history that we never see
where events play out completely
differently perhaps different Avengers
maybe no Hydra Winter Soldier program
maybe Tony Stark's parents don't die
Russo's have also said that cap would
have to use a Pym particle to return
from that alternate timeline back to
this one which I guess they could do by
re-entering that time vortex within the
quantum realm and then going back to the
branch point of origin which would be in
the 40s and then go back up that
original branch to 2023 to hand off the
shield to Sam okay just sounds like
magic just go with it meanwhile the end
games screenwriters Markus and McFeely
meam have a different take that they are
frustratingly insistent on repeating
every time they're asked about it in an
interview they say that when cap went
back to the 40s he stayed in this
timeline living out his life with Peggy
Carter presumably creeping around in the
background when his younger self emerged
from the ice to salute his own ass and
then randomly showed up sitting on a
bench at that precise moment not unlike
that time-travel daddy issues movie
frequency when elderly Dennis Quaid
barged him with a shotgun at the
miraculous moment to save the son
despite how weird it is that in that new
revised timeline the old man must have
just been sitting in a chair with a
shotgun for hours and hours while his
son was being attacked by his
former enemy and then just showed up at
the last second to what win the dramatic
timing award now I obviously have a lot
of issues with time travel logic and
movies but mmm aren't even sticking to
their own rules of time-travel that they
laborious Lee put in their movie
we're in significant changes to the past
must create new branch timeline not
suggest weird old super soldiers were
creeping around in the background of
every MCU film that we've been watching
but now knowing that old man cap is 106
years old clarify some of that confusion
Steve Rogers was born on July 4th 1918
most of N game takes place in the Year
2023 but that final scene could take
place sometime after maybe 2024 so 1918
to 2024 gets you 106 years but cap
obviously didn't age that entire period
of time from 1945 to 2011 he was frozen
in the ice he was 27 when he went down
and when he thought out in 2011 he was
still 27 so in Avengers in game he would
be around 39 or 40 years old that would
mean when 39 year old cap went back in
time to be with Peggy he would have
lived another 67 years of life with her
before coming back as Clint Eastwood to
meet Sam the screenwriters said that the
exact year that cap went back was in
1948 so that's three years after cap
went to the ice that would lead Peggy
three years to grieve before cap comes
from the future 12 years older than when
she last saw him and it just works so
the problem with the screenwriters
explanation 1948 plus 67 years is 2015
but this bench moment is 2023 or 2024
the VFX team would have to use 115 as
the base age for old man cap but they
specifically said 106 alternatively cap
could have gone back to the year 1956 to
1957 but I don't know this close in
shots of that old car in the
neighborhood or more America in 1940s in
America 1950s based on my expertise from
watching back to the future and Pearl
Harbor and 11 or 12 years for Peggy
Carter to grieve it's just too long a
time to expect a woman to wait before
coming back from the dead and the
writers themselves said in 48 so the
only way the age of 106 works for cap is
if we used the Russos interpretation cap
at age 39 went back to be with Peggy in
1948 causing a new branch history to
split off cap lived sixty seven years
with Peggy and yeah he freed Bucky from
Hydra captivity saved Tony Stark's
parents he prevented every terrorist
attack and then around the Year 2015
67 years later when he would be around
106 years old cap thinks to himself huh
20 boards coming up and I don't know
what happens in history after that so
people are gonna be mighty upset with me
when lots of bad stuff starts to happen
and I can't do nothing about it and 2015
is the year Pym tech gets refined when
Hank Pym worked with Scott Lang and the
events of ant-man so around this time
old man cap hobbles over to connect with
old man Pym and then uses the Pym tech
to return to a different timeline our
home timeline because apparently it's
very important for Sam Wilson to say
goodbye and get a new shield so there
you have it thanks to math and the true
heroes of these of interest movies the
VFX artists we finally have one proven
logical explanation for how r and r beat
em and em so what version of
time-traveling Avengers endgame makes
the most sense to you comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at a vas and
subscribe the new rock stars for
breakdowns and theories about everything
marvel thank you for joining me and I
know it's rude to ask someone their age
but they stoled man a cap we can now
sleep at night
[Music]